i know it's been hard and a struggle and
it's just great to see that you got to
the other side
any advice for hardware founders on you
know as we wrap here
what what the secrets are to running one
of these companies or does it just raise
a
[ __ ] ton of money no i think we were the
best opposite
i'd actually say the opposite i you know
we started really small you know our
seed was two mil
our a we did in a couple tranches about
five six million each
um you know and i think test improve
right test and iterate make sure you got
product market fit
you know and when you have that then i
think you feel more confident to raise
more capital i think some of the
hardware
companies that went under a lot of it
was they raised too much too fast
right like jawbone raised a ton right i
figured there was like a billion
i love my jawbone products yeah same i
like i had the jam box you know
i think there was some cool stuff i mean
they were so early to so much
yeah i love hassani yeah i think even
you know i
don't know everything that happened
obviously at any of these companies but
you know some some of them i think you
know jucero raised a lot of money at one
point
sure i don't think it was completely bad
there's clearly people who love the
product but
um you know i think there's there's a
lot of examples of hardware i think you
raised too much too fast your investor
expectations are
are too high um you know so i think i'd
actually say just like software
um be iterative the unfortunate part
about hardware is it takes more time
right yeah you got to get the product
you got to qualify you got to test all
the components you got to ship it then
you got to test the damn thing then you
got to load
firmware middleware on it so you know it
is like running three four
organizations in one so be patient but
look i think i think we're seeing it
come back right peloton i think really
helped
you sell it now with mirror and tempo a
bunch of these other companies tonal is
incredible
yeah i just ordered the hydro so i have
the rowing machine
yeah i have the peloton tread which just
got
recalled i think that was a little um
[Music]
all treadmills have sadly killed
children and pets i don't think this was
unique to them
i think they're just being super super
cautious but i'm not sure any child or
dog should be anywhere near a treadmill
this is like super dangerous
yeah um so i actually think that they
may have
overreacted on their recall um and i
don't know
because i don't think many i i'm not
recalling one i don't think i don't know
what they're going to do to make it
safer
i put a bumper on the back or something
i haven't gotten i haven't spent that
much time looking at it
so i thought there was an issue with
like the screen dislodging on some of
them
like no the issue was and there's tragic
videos online
kids will play with the treadmill so
what does the kid do they put their
hands on the back of the treadmill
then they get sucked under the treadmill
they move so fast
one kid's playing with the speed which
is what i would do and then
my little brother which is what he would
do would be trying to grab the back of
it or whatever
and they get sucked under it and then
the wheel is burning them so there's
been a lot of
gnarly things that happen with
treadmills my rule is i unplug
the safety key and yeah put it in
another location
and i unplug it and what they really
need is a pin key
just put a pin key on this and the
issue's over then a kid would have to
have the safety key the pin key the
power
i mean it would be three steps you know
it's tech companies get held to a such a
higher standard you deal with a lot of
people ripping off the idea and like
doing
bogus versions on amazon i see i noticed
when i searched one time
there were like lots of ripoff products
so those yeah we
we've seen that but most of us have you
know come and gone i think you know
really at least you know volume wise
size wise or even capital now at this
point after we've
scaled you know been scaling i think you
know i haven't haven't seen that too
much earlier on we definitely did but